i waited six hours for an ambulance
which they said they weren't gonna send
one
and some coin blokes took me in a car
before stuart hardwick broke his arm
after he fell over waiting for the bus
he was brought here to coventry hospital
and now he's tested positive for covid
when did you find out that you tested
positive for covid
but
chill how it should go this is the
challenge facing hospitals like coventry
around eighty percent of its covert
cases are patients who are not primarily
suffering from the virus but need
treatment for something else
the hospital is effectively learning to
live with covid and now the prime
minister says
it's time for the country to do the same
why did the current encouraging trends
in the data continue
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early
looks like we've got a busy day in the
cath lab again so professor kieran patel
has been preparing his hospital for
business as usual
and that means trying to function as
they did before the pandemic but with
the virus still in circulation
infection control is paramount and has
been paramount throughout the pandemic
but of course just like any measures
related to the pandemic we will be
phasing back into business as usual so
as far as your concern is your hospital
now
managing covid19 as if it's endemic
rather than a pandemic i am quietly
confident i think this is the beginning
of the end
like the hospital the prime minister
says his decisions are also driven by
the data
this is a hugely important and
significant moment the prime minister is
effectively calling the end of the
pandemic but we're still recording over
a thousand deaths a week and for some
people it's just too soon
our most vulnerable are worried they are
being put at risk there is a narrative
amongst some sections of society that
goes well if you're vulnerable and
you're worried just stay in then well
you know what actually we've done that
for nearly two years since march 2020
we'd like our lives and our liberties
back as well more more than anybody we
really miss those like normal things too
stewart's tests are continuing he might
require more treatments
i told him what the prime minister had
just announced so it's not over as far
as you're concerned
as far as i'm concerned
in coventry hospital